vous avez raison les collectivités
locales sont celles qui investissent le
plus et qui soutiennent l'économie
bien sûr de l'ensemble du territoire il
ne faut pas malgré la crise qui touche
durement l'ensemble du pays
il ne faut pas faire les erreurs du
passé et baisser les dotations au moment
où nous devons justement rétablir les
finances publiques et avoir une
solidarité nationale sur tous les
aspects que vous connaissez dans les
divers projets loi de finances que nous
avons proposées c'est pour ça que le
premier ministre après la décision ne
pas s'engager vers la baisse des
dotations et de discuter avec les
associations d'élus
jacqueline gourault sébastien lecornu
ollier du soft et moi même avons eu
plusieurs réunions avec tous tes
associations d'élus et première annonce
que ce premier ministre réunira vendredi
à l'hôtel matignon
les communes les associations autour des
communes et le bloc intercommunale bien
sûr les départements et puis l'outre-mer
qui est très spécifique évidemment dans
les difficultés que nous connaissons
évidemment devant les difficultés les
communes et les collectivités locales de
manière générale ne sont pas toutes
logées à la même enseigne seulement 30 %
de leurs recettes sont sensibles à
l'activité économique et 30 % quand même
et on voit bien que dans les zones
touristiques dans ceux qui touchent des
redevances à l'eau en outre-mer
évidemment l'année prochaine
singulièrement les départements même si
droits de mutation sont concerné cette
année c'est l'année prochaine sans doute
qu'ils seront le plus touchés nous
devons résoudre à résoudre ces problèmes
et donc le premier est respecté que dans
le projet de 6 ans rectificatif numéro 3
tel que je m'y étais engagé devant votre
assemblée lors du plfr numéro deux et
numéro un et il y aura des dispositions
relatives aux collectivités locales
le premier ministre évidemment rendra
les derniers arbitrages après avoir
écouté associations d'élus l'ufc tva
pourrait en faire partie c'est 6
milliards dans la finance que vous avez
voté cette année il ya des avantages et
des inconvénients nous avons missionné
un parlementaire monsieur cazeneuve qui
va rendre son rapport
et qui va apporter des pistes le fct a
peut en faire paris partie pardon avec
une petite difficulté c'est que c'est un
one shot bien sûr puisque si vous
avancez tout la première année se pose
la question de la deuxième année et le
sujet d'investissements sera plus en
2021 encore me semble-t-il que pour 2020